you play the journalist who blows the
lid off of the anna dalby story as a
person named anna how hard was it to say
anna all day
a lot it was it was pretty hard and
honestly what it was hard was we also
have anna davier smith
and so and we were often in the same
scenes and then also was really funny
because plenty of our our directors and
crew members also couldn't keep track of
who was if there was an anna or an anna
and like we're all anna's and it yeah it
was it was yeah we had we went by
characters
they might have a story her name is anna
delvey or anna sorokin no one's short
she's either on rich german heiress or
she's flat broke the charges are insane
committed real white-collar felonies
while posing as a socialite in an
attempt to steal millions of dollars
what made you want to take on this role
of this incredible inspired by real life
journalist jessica pressler vivian i was
so
compelled by how
shonda was um
really really
diving into the journey of vivian more
than just using um her in any way is
just like a a delivery of information
you know it it's um i think it can be
too tempting sometimes to have um a
journalist character be you know just
serve that function and and there's
nothing wrong with that but there's
something so right
about the way we do it that way yeah
i was so surprised like pleasantly
surprised to see this uh
through line of motherhood for her and
how it made her so emotionally connected
was that based on a reality of jessica's
life or was that added for the show
jessica was yes that i think that was
definitely inspired i think that that is
one of the things that just took um took
shonda on a ride with this is
jessica was really really close to um
delivering when she was um completing
this article there's the the shift of
life in in becoming a new mother yeah
also
understanding what the what the industry
and its shift is meaning for
uh vivian and then also on top of it
when we're when we're
exploring relationship and what
friendships mean to each other
to to understand that like sitting in
front of another human being and asking
them to give them their story
that's a really intimate and very unique
type of relationship as well and so
for me to get to play
um
how how anna delvey affects yeah
is um is just to me so delicious and i
enjoyed it
hi anna
i just had some questions
i have a question
what's you wearing you look poor
i have to tell you as a journalist i
felt you all nailed it i'm like i've
been in that seat i've been thinking how
can i be a human but also i need this
it's hard music to my ears thank you
it means the world to hear that thank
you how much research did you do with
jessica how much did you meet with her
to play this fictionalized version of
her she was so available to me however i
um
kind of tried to stay out of her kitchen
a little bit i um we met at table reads
and i it was really important to me to
check in with her and make sure that
it's going in the direction she feels
comfortable with um
and then from there
i really um
i really just just
voraciously read all of her notes all of
her uh published material how much is
that all the notes and everything how
how many pages of discovery oh it's nice
and thick but i was so grateful i was so
grateful and they're funny her posts are
hilarious um
and uh but yeah it's it it was
to me for such a cerebral character and
somebody who's so connected to her own
curiosity i felt like the pen to page
was my best dive in uh to to grounding
vivian so yeah that was my that was my
weigh-in and what was it like to get
back in that headspace of becoming a
first-time mom to wear the belly
oh yeah that was that was something else
that was something else it was
interesting because the actual
physicality of
the belly
in all of its different iterations
um
it still feels like it's that still
feels like it's just weight put on you
know it doesn't feel like it it doesn't
immediately get you into the muscle
memory so you still have to play it a
bit and so i was grateful to know that
feeling you know all the way and of
course every pregnancy is different so
um i had to really track
vivian's pregnancy and you know that's
not the same thing as mine you know what
i mean it's i i had different types of
pains and different types of moments and
different types of scares or whatever
yeah in in my pregnancies that she did
so it was like a separate sort of
character filter to put on are you
pregnant are you just
so very very fat
it's a funny thing you know we we're
also trauma aware and i'm so grateful
labor labor can be a really it can it
can be painful for some women for me it
i mean literally painful yes yes
but i also mean like emotionally for me
um they were traumatic in that
everything is defined as before and
after um however they were they were i i
revere my labor experiences yeah um and
and yet
yes doing that labor scene was
was there was a there was an uh
an aspect of catharsis in it but um we
were screaming
yeah i i was acting like that's the
funny thing like you know like i was
like i still have like the scene
analysis of what you know she's trying
to achieve this yes i was totally a
pedigree the same way i would but um but
thank you but yeah the muscle memory was
was wild what it was like for you all
instead there's all these amazing female
roles which i loved how much did you all
i mean julia and katie and laverne did
you bond did you laugh what was that
like oh god yeah it was
it was such this is this is such a joy
it was a i looked i woke up
even at the early early hours grateful
and excited to go to work every day this
was these are wonderful wonderful actors
and uh wonderful crew and and we had we
had a lot of female leadership on our
crew as well which was beautiful you're
part of shondaland now too yes oh it's
i'm telling you
it's everything it's cracked up to be
the fact that you know to say that like
it's really that and more i um you know
she's she's such an example of how
a great workplace can be led well and
led respectfully and um you know and
she's just everybody's champion and the
bottom line even even if she were acting
selfishly for that it gets better work
out of your workers can i ask dude now
that you're in that club like do you get
an email with bridgerton spoilers
absolutely not
there have been some you know there was
some discussion about anna herself
selling the rights for this show did
that give you any reservations how did
you grapple with that
i mean i for me it's you know i i i get
the the luxury of not having to worry
about the business end of these things
you know it's my job to just tell the
story um you know as a as just a person
who's interested in stuff that's always
fascinating i'm still trying to figure
out what the actual
what their actual um i'm sure i could
look it up somewhere but i always get it
messed up of what she's actually allowed
to earn it's not my business it's not
it's complex but it's complex of like
what yeah like what the judge's ruling
on that was because there was something
about that your character is trying to
figure anna out what do you think the
message is of this story what do you
think gets figured out through the show
what will the audience take away ooh i
think if anything gets figured out which
i i really um i would say it's that
nothing gets figured out which is the
whole point um you know i think that we
all like to believe that there's
certainty everywhere
and um i think that we're all starting
to learn of course that there's a lot
less certainty than we'd like to learn
that we'd like to think
and sometimes it's right in in you know
the human being that's facing you